let's continue with our study of the
planet lubricon 6. now the one thing i
did not tell you in the last video is
that lubricon 6 is not
is not rotating
at all and because it's not rotating it
can really not have an equator so when
we talked about the path of this frozen
sock instead of saying this traveling
across an equator i should have said
it's traveling along a great circle if
you assume earth is a sphere and it's
not a perfect sphere but if you assume
it's a sphere our equator would be a
perfect sphere but in order to have an
equator you need to have some rotation
this right over here we'll just say it's
traveling along the largest possible
circle that it can travel along it's
traveling along one of the great circles
of this sphere this block of sock right
over there and now that we know it's not
rotating i want to enter another thought
experiment because this little frozen
block of sock is not the only thing
that's on the surface of lubricon 6.
over here we were viewing it at a
distance but right over there if we were
to zoom in you would see sitting on the
surface of lubricant 6
sitting on the surface of lubricant 6.
so once again that's the surface is a
frozen banana so this right over here is
a block
of ice and in that block of ice we have
a banana it's a frozen banana so that's
my best attempt at drawing our banana
and this relative to the surface of
lubricant six is absolutely stationary
it has absolutely no tangential velocity
like this block had and will continue to
have for all eternity this has
absolutely no tangential velocity and so
my question for you if we think about
what are the net what are the forces
acting on this well we have the force of
gravity towards the center of lubricant
six so we have the force of gravity and
i'm drawing all the forces from the
center of mass of this block of banana
so once again let me draw that same
color we have the force of gravity
acting radially inward
the force of gravity acting radially
inward
and then we don't we know that this
banana is not plummeting straight into
the center of the earth there must be
some other net force that or some other
force that is keeping it stationary and
that force is the force of the surface
of lubricant 6 on the banana or on this
block that's keeping it from plunging
towards the center of the planet so that
in this case is the normal force
that is the normal force
so that is the normal force and my
question to you
is are these two things equal in the
case of the banana
well as far as we can tell this banana
is completely at rest this planet right
over here at least relative to the
planet this planet right here has
absolutely no rotation and this banana
has no relative motion towards the
planet it is not accelerating in
absolutely any direction and if it's not
accelerating in any direction the net
forces on it in any dimension must all
or must be zero or all of the forces
must cancel out with each other so in
the case of this banana the normal force
exactly cancels out the force of gravity
these two things
the normal force the normal force is
exactly equal to the inward force of
gravity or i guess we should say that
they add to zero they're going in
opposite directions so i should say the
normal force plus
the force of gravity plus the force of
gravity are going to be equal zero they
have the same exact magnitude they're
going in opposite directions so when you
add them together they are going to
cancel out
now with that little thought experiment
out of the way let's return to the
frozen sock the frozen sock as we
already learned is orbiting around this
planet at a altitude of zero for all
eternity at one kilometer per hour and
we know that there has the force of
gravity is acting on it towards the
center of the planet and there is a
normal force that's keeping it from
plummeting from spiraling towards the
center of the planet but my question to
you is in the case of the frozen
saccharide over here are these two
forces equal like they are for the
banana
so in the case of the frozen sock the
traveling orbiting sock if these two
forces were had the same magnitude or
they're essentially if they had the same
magnitude but just going in opposite
directions the way we've drawn it right
over here they would completely cancel
out and then we would have no net force
so let me make it clear if
if the normal force
plus the force of gravity
plus the force of gravity canceled out
with each other if this equaled zero
then we would have absolutely no net
force
no
net force and the object would not
accelerate in any direction an object in
motion will stay in motion so this one
right over here if it had no net force
at no net force acting on it it would
not stay on the surface of the planet it
would just travel in a straight line in
a tangential line from where it happens
to be this moment forever so if it was
if it was right over here i know this
isn't the path it would just keep
traveling forever off the surface off
the surface of the planet we know that
clearly is not what's happening it is
orbiting around the planet it has a
circular path and since it has a
circular path so if i were to draw a
cross section of its if i look its path
from the side it has a circular path
like that it is going like that is
constantly being accelerated it is
constantly being accelerated inward
there's a there's some centripetal
acceleration going on inward
acceleration so in order for that inward
acceleration to be going on there must
be some net inward force so in this
situation in this situation for the
stationary banana these two guys
canceled each other out but for the case
of the moving frozen sock the
sock that is orbiting for all of
eternity
it is in orbit it has a circular path so
there are centripetal motion there is
some net inward force going on here so
in this situation the for the magnitude
of the force of gravity the magnitude of
the force of gravity is going to be
greater than the magnitude
the magnitude of the normal force so we
don't have this situation that situation
you wouldn't orbit we have the situation
where you do have some net centripetal
force the force of gravity the magnitude
of it is slightly larger than the
magnitude of the normal force and an
interesting thing to think about and we
might address it in a future tutorial is
what would happen if this started going
faster and faster and faster if the
frozen sock were to accelerate what then
how would the relationship between these
two things potentially change if they
change at all